sie haben dieser Tage geschrieben dieses
Land hat noch ganz andere Sorgen als
Heizungen womöglich sogar
existenziellere und ihre Behandlung wäre
die Sache Karl Lauterbachs
nämlich ja also Herr Lauterbach ist im
Moment dafür zuständig dass die
Krankenhäuser die teuer sind im
doppelten Sinne also uns auch unsere
Gesundheit auch teuer sein sollten
dass wir davon sehr viele haben wir
haben viele Krankenhausbetten wir haben
zu viele Operationen dort und Herr
Lauterbach schickt sich an
eine Reform anzuschieben allerdings hat
er dabei schon ein paar Mitstreiter
Mitstreiterinnen die haben müsste von
Kopf gestoßen und im Moment
wahrscheinlich immer kleiner zu werden
glaube ich in also Bundesminister und
die Landesministerien die werden alle
sagen ja wir müssen dringend was tun die
Krankenhäuser die werden so nicht
überleben und die medizinische
Versorgung wird so auch nicht auf gute
Niveau gehalten werden und das Ziel ist
das gleiche aber den Weg den gemeinsamen
den finden Sie gerade immer weniger also
der Nenner wird immer kleiner noch mal
konkret was heißt das
die Länder müssen mitmachen wenn Herr
Lauterbach eine Reform macht weil die
Länder müssen im Grunde in den Beton in
die Häuser eine Krankenhäuser
investieren die legen fest was im
Bundesland tatsächlich an
Krankenhausbetten und wo gebraucht wird
und alles was eine medizinische
Behandlung geht das muss er Lauterbach
machen und deshalb müssen beide
zusammenarbeiten und das funktioniert
nicht gut okay ich habe es ja vorhin
gesagt wir sollten heute mal versuchen
ein bisschen grundsätzlicher zu werden
das ist ein Gesundheitssystem dass wir
uns leisten dass gar nicht so schlecht
ist wie es häufig gemacht wird sagen
auch sie das funktioniert in vielen
Teilen relativ gut und es gibt auch gute
Medizin entgegen dem Image dass da
manchmal so geprägt wird aber und das
scheint der Punkt zu sein es geht so
nicht weiter wir können uns das nicht
mehr leisten schlicht und ergreifen wie
viele Krankenhäuser werden wir sie
schließen müssen ich werde gar keins
schließen und wenn die Reform die jetzt
kommen wird wenn diese Form nicht käme
dann würde das Krankenhaus sterben
heute im nächsten Jahr beginnen und
hätte aber dann auch auf lange Zeit kein
Ende wir werden nicht mehr verhindern
können dass im nächsten Jahr
Krankenhäuser große Schwierigkeiten
haben vielleicht auch in Insolvenz gehen
aber diese Reform die ist ja seit
mindestens 10 möglicherweise seit 15
Jahren überfällig und wir werden diese
Reformen seine riesige Reform an der
arbeiten wir jetzt schon seit vielen
Monaten sehr gut mit den Ländern
zusammen wir werden die Reform fertig
bekommen das ist eine gigantische reform
was wir nicht gemacht haben wir haben
die Reform nicht also sonderlich jetzt
abgestimmt mit den üblichen Lobbygruppen
im System sondern wir haben mit
Wissenschaft und zusammengearbeitet wir
haben eine Regierungskommission
Krankenhaus das sind absolute
Top-Experten das sind Leute die in der
die große notfallabteilungen in Berlin
leiten die also in der Intensivmedizin
Arbeiten
Gesundheitsökonomen Epidemiologen also
topwissenschaftler die haben für viele
Monate uns beraten machen das auch jetzt
noch und wir werden am nächsten
Donnerstag mit den dann kommen wir sehr
gut zurecht also wir kommen sehr gut
zusammen wir werden am nächsten
Donnerstag wahrscheinlich Eckpunkte
beschließen und werden das Gesetz im
über den Sommer schreiben also unser
Haus und dann drei Länder werden
beteiligt sein wahrscheinlich
Nordrhein-Westfalen Baden-Württemberg
und Hamburg so dass wir da ausgewogen
sind was die Parteien angeht und ich
glaube dass diese große Reform das ist
dem komplett umkrempeln wird
was wird da passieren ganz einfach also
Bezahlen im Moment werden Moment also
300 Milliarden jedes Jahr
im Krankenhaus beim Krankenhaus sind das
etwa 100 Milliarden aber ich will ganz
viele vorlässig einfach simpel erklären
wir haben derzeit
1300 Prozeduren und Fälle die jeweils
einen Preis haben das System
funktioniert so der Patient kommt rein
hat nämlich hinter Diagnose dann gibt's
für diese Diagnose einen Preis das ist
die fahrpauschale und je mehr Fälle ich
mache desto mehr Geld habe ich indem sie
und das bedeutet muss man einmal klären
es ist Russlands kommt rein kaputtes
Knie vielleicht noch also eine
nebendiagnose
hyperaktiv dann würde man sagen das ist
das ist jetzt das ist jetzt der Preis
von Markus Lanz dann
klingt behandelt wird dann ist das der
Preis den es gibt 4000 Euro zum Beispiel
je nachdem was am Knie dran ist kann man
damit über die Runde genau und somit
müssen die Krankenhäuser also müssen
versuchen so viele Fälle zu machen wie
möglich dabei wird das ein oder andere
Knie operiert was vielleicht gar nicht
operiert werden müsste schon mal das
erste Problem das zweite Problem ist
wenn ich jetzt keinen topchirurgen habe
für Knie will aber trotzdem die 4000 €
abrechnen dann auch bereit operiert
vielleicht jemand der nicht so gut mit
dem Knie ist wird Markus Lanz nie
erfahren dass dann besser so in der
Nachbar Klinik das besser gemacht hätte
und vielleicht hat man dann auch noch
die Überlegung wir machen das stationär
obwohl man es ambulant machen könnte
schon wieder das Geld weg und so
funktioniert das System wir machen viel
zu viel stationär was wir ambulant
machen könnten wir machen auch Fälle die
wir nicht unbedingt machen müssten und
wir machen auch Fälle dort wo man sie
eigentlich nicht machen sollte
beispielsweise
Krebsbehandlungen machen wir nicht in
den Kliniken die dafür besonders
ereignet sind zumindest nicht alle und
daher sind die Fachgesellschaft die
Krebsgesellschaft die Fachgesellschaft
für als Gasthof Krankenhaus Krankheiten
die sind alle für die Reform weil die
sehen in erster Linie mit der Reform
kann man nicht so viel Geld sparen
sondern das wird viele Menschen leben
dürfen ich habe vorhin kurz um andere
sozusagen das große Ganze mal zu
verstehen sie haben diesen Artikel
geschrieben den ich in sehr guten
Artikel finde deswegen lesenswert weil
man einmal kapiert was das eigentlich
für ein System ist wie viel Geld das
kostet wie viel Geld das in Zukunft
kosten wird das ist immer teurer wird
das ist eigentlich was die Kosten angeht
völlig aus dem Ruder läuft
und gleichzeitig sagen sie wir haben
aber gar nichts davon also da steigen
jetzt noch mal die Beiträge es wird
alles jetzt noch teurer wir müssen immer
mehr Geld zuschießen gleichzeitig sind
die Deutschen nicht gesünder sie werden
nicht unbedingt besser behandelt und es
gibt sogar sagen sie mit Blick zum
Beispiel auf Dänemark Herzinfarkt ist
ein Beispiel vielleicht können Sie es
einmal daran beschreiben was der
Unterschied ist warum sind die Dänen
beispielsweise bei der Behandlung von
Herzinfarkten besser als wir wohl unser
Gesundheitssystem um ein Vielfaches
teurer ist das fängt schon damit an wenn
Notfall ausgelöst wird 112 gewählt wird
und dann der Rettungswagen kommt wissen
die die einen holen nicht unbedingt die
Vorgeschichte und die gesundheitlichen
Vorbedingungen das weiß man in Dänemark
weil das alles auf einer elektronischen
Gesundheit verzeichnet ist da fängt
schon mal an die können schon viel
genauer dann auch in ein Krankenhaus
bringen das auch genau aus gewesen ist
in Dänemark was für eine
versorgungsanbietet nämlich für
Herzinfarkt gut geeignet oder eben nicht
angefahren wird das wird in Deutschland
nicht gemacht also in Deutschland
rechnen doppelt so viele Krankenhäuser
Herzinfarkte ab also behandeln auch
akute Herzinfarkte als zum Beispiel
linksherzkatheter haben was sehr wichtig
ist in so einem akuten Notfall und die
Überlebensrate auch enorm erhöht und
wenn ich etwas sozusagen in Berlin dann
Krankenhaus habe mit linksherzkatheter
aber genauso weit eins ohne und ich dann
dorthin gefahren werde werde ich nicht
erfahren dass mein Überlebenschancen
sehr viel geringer sind in Deutschland
versterben 8% der Herzinfarkt Patienten
mehr als 80 Prozent in Krankenhaus in
Dänemark nur 3%
versus 3%, weil man eben genauer die
Patienten hinbringt genauer sie
behandeln kann und damit dann eben kann
man das auch in Überlebensraten müssen
ja bevor tut das ist ja die Reform die
seit 15 Jahren fehlt und die ich gerade
mache sie beschreiben im Prinzip die
Reform des unsere Reform sieht vor dass
die Herzinfarkte in die Klinken gebracht
werden
die Krankenhäuser haben bessere
Ergebnisse die 24 Stunden 7 Tage die
Woche bei einem Herzinfarkt sofort mit
einem Katheter dass die Verstopfung in
dem Koronargefäß auflösen können kommen
Sie jetzt mit dem Infarkt in einer
Klinik die das nicht kann dann denken
sie es würde ihnen geholfen weil dann
läuft ein Tropfen sie denken okay die
die also die Versorgung also ich finde
die Stadt sie würden aber nie erfahren
dass eigentlich eine andere Versorgung
nämlich dass das Gefäß wird wieder
geöffnet in der Klinik in der sie jetzt
sind nicht möglich ist weil da wird kein
Spezialisten kommen und sagen schade
dass jetzt bei uns sind ein paar fünf
Kilometer weiter hätte man ihnen jetzt
ganz anders helfen können das und das
wollen wir halt ändern da ist diese
Reform eine qualitätsreform und wird
daher von allen deutschen Universitäten
unterstützen noch mal zum zur aus
gangslage liegt die Frage des großen
Krankenhaus Sterbens das klingt ja
beängstigend wenn man das erstmal so
hört von sie haben ich glaube es war
auch in diesem Artikel ein Beispiel
beschrieben dass ich extrem prägnant
fand es gibt eine Untersuchung
Ruhrgebiet
Knieverletzung wie viele Krankenhäuser
könnte man ansteuern wenn man in
Dortmund beispielsweise plötzlich ein
Problem mit dem Knie hat ein bisschen
ältere Untersuchung aber es ist war eine
Untersuchung wenn man am Hauptbahnhof in
Essen steht im Umkreis von einer halben
Stunde wie viel mal man seinen Knien
verschiedenen Häusern operiert haben
könnte also es war 20 und zweistelligen
Bereich dass man 20 Häuser ansteuern
kann die das ähnlich anbieten aber mit
unterschiedlichsten Qualität und
Ergebnissen wir sind es aber auch in der
Problembeschreibung sind wir uns
überhaupt nicht uneins da sind alle in
einig dass wir zu viel machen nicht
immer gut und deshalb nicht sozusagen
zum Thema Krankenhaus wie viele
Krankenhäuser haben wir in Deutschland
1719.7.19 genau deswegen sind
schätzungsweise wie viele irgendwann
bald nicht mehr da
wenn wir nichts Daten dann würde also
sicherlich ein unkontrolliertes
Krankenhaus sterben losgehen ich sage
mal 20 25 Prozent würden in den nächsten
Jahren verschwinden wahrscheinlich aber
mehr 20 25 Prozent werden Weg werden Weg
mindestens unseren weitergehen sie
wollen die jetzt schließen oder was wird
jetzt passieren ich will gar nicht über
diese schließungsdiskussion ist für mich
nicht so spannend für mich ist es
einfach für arbeiten
weil Politiker traut sich zu sagen dass
man eben an bestimmten Stellen schließen
muss wenn es konkret wird dann fürchten
alle die die Jugendliche Menschen können
Sie mir doch nicht vorwerfen ich werde
doch jeden Tag in der Presse auch von
also ihren Kolleginnen und Kollegen zum
Teil dafür kritisiert dass ich eine
Reform mache wo auch Krankenkasse
geschlossen werden ich sage ja sogar
dass unsere Frauen noch nichtmals
verhindern wird das Krankenhaus
geschlossen werden das ist können sie
mir ja nicht vorwerfen von anderen
Politikern aber wenn ich jeden Abend
sagen worum es mir geht also was wir
machen werden wir werden also die
Krankenhäuser bewerten wie gut ist die
Qualität für welchen Eingriff zum Januar
des nächsten Jahres ich hoffe dass die
ich gehe davon aus dass die Reform zum
ersten ersten 24 steht die Reform die
seit 15 Jahren benötigt wurde die haben
wir dann in einem Jahr gemacht da wird
dann regional auf einer Karte können Sie
dann das Krankenhaus anklicken wo sie
mit dem Knie hingehen wollen und dann
können Sie sehen die machen den Eingriff
Knie diese Leistungsgruppe ja oder nein
und die machen das entweder gut oder wir
haben Qualitätsdefizite und wenn sie
qualitätsdefizit haben dann werden wir
nach einer Übergangsphase vielleicht ein
Jahr auch nicht mehr bezahlen das heißt
der Bund der muss jetzt dem der
sozusagen
schlecht gemacht wird einfach
ausgedrückt wo wir das belegen können da
sind keine Kniespezialisten die
Eingriffe werden nicht oft genug gemacht
es gibt viele Komplikationen das werden
wir öffentlich machen wir werden also
jedes Krankheit
alle 1719 Krankenhäuser können Sie dann
anklicken meinetwegen auf Spiegel Online
oder was können Sie anklicken was machen
wir öffentlich dann sehen sie das
Krankenhaus dann sehen Sie die
Leistungsgruppen 63 Leistungsgruppen
dann sehen sie ist dass da grün dann ist
die Qualität stimmig ist es rot gibt es
ein Qualitätsproblem die
Fachgesellschaften die Wissenschaftler
die uns beraten die werden das Auswerten
machen wir mit den Wissenschaftlern
zusammen und nach einer Übergangsphase
bezahlen wir nicht mehr wo die Qualität
schlecht ist der springende Punkt ist
wenn ich in all den Kliniken die Dinge
nicht mehr bezahlen die die Kliniken
nicht gut können dann gehen diese
Patienten für diese Eingriffe in Klinken
wo das gut ist dann kann dort auch
besser bezahlt werden weil ich war ja
sehr viel Geld und somit die anderen
gehen pleite das sollten wir jetzt auch
dazu sagen wenn die wenn ich jetzt in
vielen Bereichen Probleme habe dann wird
das Haus sich nicht halten können es wir
haben Häuser wir waren ja so
vorauswertungen wir haben diese Daten
für die 1 1919 Kliniken und diese 63
Fachgruppen das haben wir jetzt schon
aber wir prüfen das noch aber wir werden
das zum ersten ersten werden oder sagen
auch haben das stellen wir dann ins Netz
das wird auf jeden Fall passieren und
ersten ersten waren 24 da wird dieser
klicken an auf der Karte also
Markus Lanz also will dann sind da fünf
Kliniken die eigentlich dass jeder die
Klinik gemacht das gar nicht die Klinik
mardes hier ist eine Klinik gemacht ist
schlecht bei der Klinik der schlecht
macht werden wir im Jahr danach gar
nicht mehr bezahlen aber bei der Klinik
die ist gut macht da können sich dann
auch verlassen die kennen das und so
prüfen wir in jeder Klinik aber er kann
was gut und das ist der Grund weshalb
große Fachgesellschaft z.B
Krebsgesellschaft und unterstützt die
Reform weil sie sagen das brauchen wir
schon so lange ja der Laie muss doch
wissen wo das gut ist nicht okay
wir müssen jetzt mal aufarbeiten hier
also
das heißt es gibt sie sagen das ist eine
Qualitätskontrolle Verbesserung der
Besserung
ist schon klar es ist auch es survival
of the fittest ne sehr darwinistische
Ansatz möchte ich mal sagen ich möchte
einfach nicht die Leute die jetzt die
schlechte Behandlung bekommen es sind ja
zum Glück nicht so viel aber in einigen
Bereichen haben wir große Probleme die
Leute die jetzt diese Behandlung
bekommen das sind diejenigen die nicht
so viel Bildung haben die sich nicht
informieren können wo es keine
Verwandten gibt die Ärzte sind die sich
nicht tausendmal informieren können im
Netz und so was sind die einfachen Leute
die einfachen Leute die sind nicht
dümmer als andere aber sie nicht ja
nicht die Beziehungen die haben die sind
nicht privat versichert die haben nicht
die Kontakte die haben nicht die
Möglichkeit
und für diese Leute mache ich die Reform
mir ist es zum Schluss noch nicht mal so
wichtig ob der Mann nicht wegen
100-krankenhaus mehr oder weniger
verschwinden wenn wir noch genug
Krankenhaus haben aber mir geht es in
aller erster Linie bei dieser Reform
viele Nachfragen des also fangen sie
erstmal an Frau tut
und vielleicht reden wir mal kurz über
diesen das heißt es gibt da so eine Art
also ich nenne es jetzt mal böse an der
öffentlichen Pranger ist ja kein Pranger
wenn sie darstellen müssen ob sie die
Qualität haben aber wenn Sie wenn Sie
jetzt schon untersuchen meinetwegen
Klinik XY ist bei Schulter besonders
schlecht genau leuchtet das Ding rot
dann können sie doch eigentlich jetzt
schon zu machen nein ich mache die
erstens macht die Klinik nicht bezahlen
nicht mehr ich bezahle diesen Schulter
Eingriff nicht oder oder das beraten
wir machen das ja mit wissen wir machen
das mit der Arbeitsgemeinschaft der
wissenschaftlichen Fachgesellschaften in
ganz Deutschland zusammen und die
hungern die auch aus die die
Wissenschaftler Hunger das war gar
nichts sondern bewerten ist die Qualität
die die nein noch nicht mal weil die
Krankenhäuser die gut sind die
profitieren doch von nein
zum Beispiel werden profitieren weil die
komplizierten Fälle die eigentlich jetzt
in die Uniklinik gehören die kommen dann
da an das andere darf es nicht mehr
Entschuldigung also
ich habe gerade einen schlimmen Verdacht
also man macht sich als Politiker
natürlich nicht wirklich beliebt und
populär wenn man sagt euch mache ich zu
nein das heißt der Hebel der Umweg ist
wir stellen fest ihr seid in dem Bereich
schlecht und dann passiert was passiert
wir zahlen halt nicht mehr dafür und
dann seid ihr in einem Jahr tot ja das
wird so nicht sein also die kleineren
Kliniken z.B die bekommen also das Geld
für die Kleinen Eingriffe die müssen
dann aber nicht mehr wie jetzt so viele
Fälle machen wir bezahlen den eine
pauschale 60% des Geldes bekommen die
als Pauschale damit kann wenn die dann
weniger Fälle machen dann kommen die gut
über die Runden ich will doch nur dass
die kleinen Häuser die ich für die
einfache Chirurgie die einfacher Innere
Medizin dass ich die die kriegen eine
pauschale und können über die Runden
kommen jetzt sind bedroht weil es sind
immer weniger Menschen die in die
kleinen klicken noch reingehen wollen
für große Eingriffe die gut gebildeten
die Ärzte selbst zum Beispiel zum Teil
sogar die Ärzte die ihre Patienten in
diese Klinik überweisen die kämen selbst
nie auf den Gedanken dort selbst oder
ihre Kinder hinzuschicken Frau tut hatte
Einwände und ich habe auch gleich noch
eine Frage und ich glaube sie auch erst
die Frau tut sie haben damit sozusagen
sie haben so ein
ausleseprinzipien
stattfindet ja fortsetzt aber mit
medizinischen Kriterien immerhin
versehen immerhin
aber es geht darum
eine Versorgung aufrecht erhält und die
Häuser die unter den jetzigen
Bedingungen und nicht in der Lage sind
zum Beispiel Personal zu finden oder
eine gewisse grundsätzliche
Infrastruktur zu erhalten den ist damit
schon mal gar nicht geholfen diese
Grundversorgung zu halten und der zweite
ein Mann ist ich glaube nicht dass sie
die Menschen und die Breite der
Öffentlichkeit gewinnen werden mit so
einem Prinzip weil man auch etwas
anderes noch dagegen setzen muss man
muss zum Beispiel auch sagen was ist
denn wenn dann auf dem Land kein
Krankenhaus mehr ist die Leute gehen ja
inzwischen ins Krankenhaus weil es keine
Fachärzte mehr gibt was für ein
Gesundheitszentrum was für ein Angebot
bauen wir denn dort auf sie müssen ja
auch was aufbauen was immer noch die
Menschen dann gut versorgt das tun wir
ja die kleinen Kliniken die sagen wir
diese Fälle dann nicht mehr haben das
werden dann Level 1 Kliniken die können
integrierte Versorgung anbieten die
können ambulant versorgen die können
Fachärzte sozusagen als belegas zu
beschäftigen die können die Kleinen
Eingriffe abrechnen stationär wie
ambulant kriegen immer das gleiche Geld
Gesundheitszentren werden da entstehen
das ist ja alles in dem Konzept sie
kennen das sind die Länder nicht mehr
auf ihrer Seite wie ich sage ihnen
voraus nächste Woche Donnerstag werden
wir die Eckpunkte beschließen also ich
bin nicht sicher ob wir den gleichen
Kenntnisstand haben wir sind mit denen
sind mit denen doch über Operation und
Medizin ist ein Kunstgriff
ist doch klar
wir werden über den Sommer werden wir
ein Gesetzentwurf schreiben war die
Länder wissen die Länder wissen doch sie
brauchen ihre Form wir kommen in ein
unkontrolliertes Klinik sterben die
Qualität ist schlecht wenn da eine
Reform ist wo alle Unikliniken dahinter
stehen die Fachgesellschaften der
Spitzenverband der Krankenkassen so alle
für ihre Form es gibt keinen
Gegenvorschlag da wird es doch nicht so
sein dass die Reform nachher nicht
kommen
auseinander was die Länder gerne hätten
die Länder sind der Meinung dass wir
diese Daten also wie gut ist die
einzelne Klinik kann die das kann die
das nicht in Eingriff also was ich eben
mit Rot und Grün beschrieben habe die
Länder sind der Meinung dass wir das
nicht veröffentlichen sollen aber da
haben
wenn man denkt die wie ein
Landesvertreter sagte man glaubt die
kleinen klicken da wir dann die sind
nicht nur kleine kriegen es gibt auch
große Kliniken die haben Bereichen haben
die Qualitätsdefizite aber da wurde dann
argumentiert die füllen sich da nicht
mehr aber das ist ja was ich will und
von daher also bin ich mit den Ländern
schon klar ich brauche die Zustimmung
der Länder für diese Öffentlichmachung
der Daten der Qualität brauchen Sie
nicht
Sie haben den Kunstgriff ne das brillant
also für das Form ist es brillant danke
danke
muss weil
also die Geschichte ist doch ganz
einfach Frau tut sie haben doch gerade
den Konflikt aufgemacht sie haben doch
gerade gesagt Herr Lauterbach kann gar
keine Kliniken schließen gegen den
Willen der Länder das machen die nicht
mit das will ich auch gar nicht genau
natürlich nicht das haben wir alle
verstanden kein Politiker sie wollen
einfach nur nicht mehr bezahlen als ein
natürlicher Tod der Eintritt ohne dass
man selber das Messer fühlen muss ich
ich zahle nicht mehr wie der Boden ist
das macht ganz einfach der Bund muss
derzeit zahlen selbst dann wenn die
Qualität nicht gut ist und das
aber was jetzt passiert Herr Lauterbach
ist doch selbst wenn Markus Söder mit
mit seiner ganzen Autorität machen genau
ich habe nicht das ist ja keine
Trickserei sondern ich sage das doch
seit alt das ist eine ehrliche
politische Verbesserung unseres
Krankenhaus Wesens das ist doch kein
Trick wenn ich sage wir wollen nicht
mehr das Qualität die nein das verstehe
ist dass die bezahlt werden muss wir
müssen die Patienten schützen und wir
müssen die Qualität dennoch öffentlich
es ist alles okay
das ist nein das ist alles okay aber es
ist trotzdem sehr trickreich und
interessieren wir sie gerade im Gespräch
er hat sie glaube ich noch nicht
durchschaut auf dem Foto also wenn sie
ihm sagen ihr müsst eine Klinik
schließen dann können Sie das gar nicht
da kann man das sogar sagen Freunde bei
uns wird keine Klinik geschlossen ist
weil wir brauchen die und so weiter so
wenn sie aber sagen pass auf wir zahlen
dann einfach nicht mehr wird sich die
Klinik von selbst schließen ich mache
einfach die rote Ampel dran die rote
Laterne für die dann schließlich diese
Klinik ganz von selbst die ganze Kirche
genau
OP ist auch schlecht wir haben einen
Kliniken da bündelt genau wir haben
Kliniken ja da bündeln sich die sag mal
lass uns Probleme muss
wahrscheinlich nicht überleben wird so
aber ich
1719 Kliniken ist das ein Verlust wenn
die Klinik jetzt für die Sicherstellung
unbedingt benötigt wird die kleine
Chirurgie die kleine Innere Medizin die
Geriatrie die hals-nasen-ohrenversorgung
das ist doch dann zu leise ich will
einfach nicht dass in den verschiedenen
Krebs behandelt wird das möchte ich
nicht einfach ganz kurz also wir sind
uns doch einig darüber das was sie da
jetzt in Gang setzen das wird doch ein
ganz harten Wettbewerb auslösen klar
ganz hart auch dawinistisches Prinzip
die harten kommen in den Garten die
besten kommen durch und der Rest wird
langsam einfach abgewickelt jetzt ist es
doch passieren das wird doch passieren
es wird wenn die Reform nicht machen
passiert das gleiche aber nur für um
Geld jetzt wird Qualität entscheiden wer
bleibt und wenn ich diese Form nicht
mache wird entscheiden wer macht in dem
System Gewinne es geht beim Krankenhaus
ster Ben nur um Geld aber laut
nicht genug Geld zusammen und Katzen
kann zum Teil durch überflüssige
Eingriffe ja das ist doch kein System
das könnte auch zum Schluss ins Knie
werden ne wenn man wenn man das so macht
weil sie haben da jetzt an den
Mechanismus sozusagen den sie im Kopf
haben mit dem können Sie sie machen
das rote Licht dran und dann ist klar wo
die Reise für diese Klinik
möglicherweise die Wissenschaftler die
qualitätswissenschaftler das bin ich ich
glaube die Serie
das macht nicht Markus Söder das wird
definitiv nicht Markus Söder machen weil
genau
so und jetzt reden wir schon seit 20
Minuten und es sie erinnern sich an
meine Frage von vor ungefähr 20 Minuten
wie viele Kliniken jetzt treffen
1719 haben wir wie viele brauchen wir
realistischerweise um ein
Gesundheitssystem zu haben von dem sie
sagen so stelle ich mir idealerweise vor
so könnte es funktionieren wie viele
über diese Zahl spekuliere ich nicht
über was ich gerne hätte ist wir haben
tatsächlich also 25 Prozent 30 Prozent
25 20 25 Prozent die jetzt
insolvenzgefährdet sind da kann es gut
sein dass ein großer Teil davon stirbt
noch bevor die Reform überhaupt wird war
diese Reform hätten wir schon vor Jahren
machen müssen
also wir hätten vor Jahren diese Reform
schon machen müssen aber das ist ja
nicht mehr vorzuwerfen so ich habe
sofort damit begonnen und ich habe das
jetzt auch mit Druck gemacht
wir wollen nur verstehen was hier
passiert an einem so wichtigen Punkt
auch gesellschaftlich weil Gesundheit
ist wichtig Frau tut wenn sie wenn sie
sozusagen im Hintergrund zu ihrer
Schüler ausstrecken was ist die Sorge
also ich sag mal das kleine Provinz
Krankenhaus ist ja bin selber immer
leidenschaftlicher Provinzler gewesen ja
weil ich selber auch aus der Provinz
komme und weiß da fühlt man sich immer
so ein bisschen wie soll man sagen man
ist nicht der der der coole Großstädter
der selbstverständlich alles zur
Verfügung hat sondern man muss gucken wo
man bleibt und man schlägt sich so durch
man arrangiert sich damit und man hängt
auch an seinem kleinen
Provinzkrankenhaus ist nicht so dass man
sagt es mir völlig egal ob dieses kleine
Krankenhaus in dem man vielleicht zur
Welt gekommen ist indem man auch seine
Blinddarm-Operation gemacht hat ob es
das plötzlich morgen nicht mehr gibt das
wissen doch diese Landespolitiker das
wissen doch Leute wie Markus Söder und
andere das weiß doch ein Karl-Josef
Laumann in NRW zum Beispiel ganz genau
die wissen noch ganz genau dass das
nicht gut ankommen wird also wie groß
ist die Sorge auf der anderen Seite das
ist der echte Verwerfungen gibt also es
ist erstmal der emotionale Punkt zum
Beispiel wenn Geburtsort nicht mehr gibt
weil es kein Krankenhaus mehr gibt zum
auf die Welt kommt das ist natürlich
emotional belastet behaftet es gibt aber
auch ganz praktische ökonomische Gründe
oft ist das der größte Arbeitgeber
also es ist auch ein ökonomischer Faktor
es ist insgesamt eine Furcht von
Regionen abgehängt zu sein wenn solche
wichtigen Punkte verschwinden deshalb
ist es sehr wichtig dass man etwas
zeigt was an die Stelle tritt weil man
muss die Menschen ja versorgen gerade
die die auf dem Land sind die sind ja
die Älteren und nicht so mobilen also
und das vermisse ich dir an dieser
Reform das da gar nicht erklärt wird
oder auch beispielhaft gearbeitet wird
was an die Stelle tritt und was das wäre
ein Gesundheitszentrum wo Ärzte
praktizieren wo findet man die überhaupt
in dem Konzept drin die Level 1
e-kliniken die integrierten Kliniken das
sind Kliniken die haben keine
Notfallversorgung mehr sondern das sind
klingen da wird im Wesentlichen
stationär und ambulant gearbeitet Belege
Ärzte Hybrid wenn dort angeboten das
heißt ich kann selbst entscheiden mache
ich das ambulant oder stationär gibt es
immer das gleiche Geld es wird dort klar
gemacht dass dort auch die kleinen
chirurgischen Eingriffe Knochenbrüche
und so gemacht werden und es können dort
auch medizinische Versorgungszentren an
dem Krankenhaus sein oder im
krankenhauskommission und darüber reden
wir doch gesagt es gibt kein ein
Beispiel das richtig gut funktioniert
also in Baden-Württemberg versuchen Sie
es mit viel staatlichem Geld sowas zu
päppeln aber man muss erstmal das
Personal auch finden die Ärzte die da
zusammenarbeiten man muss das erstmal
aufbauen man muss auch vielleicht dann
sowas Dinge wie Helikopterlandeplatz
machen damit man wenn man sozusagen
nicht mehr vor Ort versorgt über lange
Strecken die Leute transportiert und das
muss man auch den Menschen nahe bringen
dass da an die Stelle etwas tritt weil
sonst ist wirklich dieser
lassen Sie mich anders verteidigen weil
sie müssen mir das nicht glauben das
müssen wir das nicht glauben aber ich
muss das wirklich sagen auch zur
Ehrenrettung der Wissenschaftler die
jetzt seit Monaten an den Konzept
arbeiten und der Bundesländer
Arbeitsgruppe ja arbeiten ja mit den 16
Ländern zusammen mit den staatssitzungen
wir treffen uns darüber wird seit
Monaten geschrieben berichtet und so
weiter den Menschen auch beispielhaft
und konkret nahe gebracht werden
nicht mehr dabei noch machen wir ja die
Reform aber was ein Level 1 eh Klinikum
ist also so ein Plan zu ambulant und
stationär verarbeitet werden kann wo
beleger zu sind wo ich selbst
entscheiden wo dann auch tagespauschal
das ist alles schon dass wir machen im
Sommer das Gesetz ich kann ja das Gesetz
den Bürgern nicht erklären bevor ich das
Gesetz gemacht habe wir reden heute hier
mal darüber und verstehen mal ein
bisschen zehn Jahre ist nichts passiert
und jetzt kommt eine komplette
Runderneuerung unseres System verstanden
das ist eine große Sache und
das wird zwangsläufig auch zu
Verwerfungen führen Herr Seifert mhh ja
Medizinische Hochschule Hannover
exzellente Einrichtung sie haben da kein
Thema
sie die Frage was geht Ihnen durch den
Kopf falls jemand der auch so tief in
diesem ganzen Gesundheitssystem drin
steckt wenn Sie das Hören also ich habe
verstanden in der Diagnose im Befund
sind wir uns ja sind auch Frau tut unter
Lauterbach sehr nah beieinander so geht
es nicht weiter schlicht deswegen weiß
nicht mehr zu bezahlen aber sozusagen
der der die soziale Dimension die Frau
tut gerade angesprochen hat
die Frage wie kommt man da hin gerade
Leute die nicht mehr besonders mobil
sind ja wie wie wie wie können die dann
dort weitermachen auch übrigens die
Frage man sagt das läuft dann alles
digital dieser Tage sehr interessanten
Artikel darüber gelesen dass viele
ältere Menschen gerade ein richtiges
Problem haben weil sie in dieser
digitalen Welt sich nicht mehr
zurechtfinden die gehen nicht ins
Internet und tippen irgendwelche
interaktiven Flächen an sondern die die
schlagen sich nur noch irgendwie mühsam
durch das heißt
was was sind ihre Ängste wenn Sie das
Hören also ich habe noch eine ganz
andere soziale Dimensionen wenn Sie so
wollen nämlich die das
gerichtsgutachters und ich sehe häufig
die Resultate von
Krankenhausbehandlungen die nicht
funktionieren natürlich im
medikamentösen Bereich und der sich auch
sehr viel soziales Leid durch
Fehlbehandlung und ich stelle mir ganz
häufig die Frage Mensch das gibt es doch
gar nicht diese Klinik müsste doch
beschlossen sein
und ich kann in dem Falle Lauterbach nur
zustimmen es gibt eben sehr kleine
Häuser und sehr große wo ich als
Gutachter dann einfach sehe da sind
massive Fehlbehandlung gelaufen und das
sind massive strukturelle Probleme und
da sind die Möglichkeiten die man hat
als Gutachter nur selimitiert und ich
würde Ihnen empfehlen wenn es diese
Möglichkeiten geben im Grunde
Gerichtsakten aufzuarbeiten als eine
evidenzbasierte
Dokumentation von Fehlern
zu sagen um diese diese dieses
rot-grün-system platzen damit ich sie
genau dem Problem das Problem dass sie
nennen damit man sagen wir mal auch eine
eindeutige Evidenz dafür hat welche
Klinik schlecht ist und ich mache viele
diese Gutachten und ich sehe das auch es
gibt Hotspots und ich kriege häufiger
auch schon mal an strukturelle
Veränderungen nur das ist nicht die
Aufgabe des Gerichtes insofern finde ich
den Ansatz von Herrn Lauterbach richtig
und man muss das natürlich gut
kommunizieren aber diesen Aspekt das
eben viele Menschen auch sterben
durchführbar den muss man auch mit
berücksichtigen und ich glaube das ist
ihre Intention dabei darf ich Frau tut
an dem Punkt vielleicht noch mal oder
möglicherweise auch sie wenn sie so viel
mit solchen Dingen zu tun haben
wo erlebt man sowas ich habe sie vorhin
zitiert dass die Deutschen leben nicht
unbedingt länger als andere Länder die
weniger Geld für ihre Gesundheitssysteme
ausgeben wir sind nicht unbedingt
gesünder aber wir zahlen unfassbar viel
Geld sie sagten das ist ein
Katastrophe das wäre jetzt auch noch die
die Kassenbeiträge erhöhen um immer
weiter Geld in ein System reinzupumpen
das offenkundig nicht wirklich gut ist
ja machen Sie das fest also ich bin
überhaupt nicht bei Herrn Lauterbach der
immer sagt ökonomisierendes
Gesundheitswesens wir haben eine
begrenzte Anzahl von Mitteln und die
müssen wir klug einsetzen dass denen die
sind dringendsten und lebensretten und
wirklich dass sie mit Lebensqualität im
Leben bleiben dass sie das Geld bekommen
und nicht die für kosmetische oder
Lifestyle oder sonstige Dinge oder so
qualifizieren wie viel Geld geben wir
aus und wo ist der Finanzbedarf in den
nächsten Jahren wie entwickelt sich das
naja eigentlich ich meine im Moment ist
der Krankenkassenbeitrag im Schnitt bei
16,2 zwei Prozent des Bruttolohns also
so viel wird abgezogen es ist ein
enormer Betrag weil man ganz viele
Menschen in Arbeit hat so viel wie noch
nie also sie kommt auch viel Geld
zusammen weil viel vom Arbeitseinkommen
weggeht und trotzdem kommen wir nicht
damit aus das spricht doch dafür dass
man Doppeluntersuchungen gibt dass die
Leute häufig zum Arzt müssen zum
Beispiel durch diese ganzen Quartals
Abrechnungen weil wir noch total
altbackenes System haben was auch sehr
viel Aufwand Durchlauf Bürokratie
verlangt und diese Dinge
noch mal MRT weil das wollen wir jetzt
mal selber kommen
weil sie ihre Rezepte abholen jedes
Quartal müssen sie wieder hin damit dann
eben wieder das ausgelöst wird das sind
so Quatsch Dinge die wir irgendwie alle
noch haben und die müsste man einfach
angehen und man muss wirklich
wirtschaftlich und sinnvoll und sparsam
mit den Mitteln umgehen die wir haben
klar das ist ja da wird jeder zustimmen
aber lassen Sie uns ganz offen
miteinander reden wir haben riesige
Probleme bei der Art und Weise
Arzneimittelpreise machen und wie wir
und trotzdem liefer Engpässe das Problem
ist seit zehn Jahren bekannt ich habe
jetzt ein Gesetz gemacht das geht morgen
durch den Deutschen Bundestag zehn Jahre
wäre es notwendig gewesen
krankenhausreform verschwenden wir Geld
haben nicht die gute Qualität 10 Jahre
wäre das notwendig gewesen wenn nicht
länger ich bin jetzt ein Jahr quasi mit
diesen Themen beschäftigt es kommt schon
das Gesetz wir haben die Digitalisierung
wir haben 15 Jahre an der elektronischen
Patientenakte gearbeitet sie ist nicht
da man ich werde sie ich werde sie im
nächsten Jahr ausräumen nächstes Jahr
das Elektron 24 also wir werden ich weiß
ich will es doch präzise machen werden
dafür sorgen dass im Jahr 25
80% der Deutschen die elektronische
Patientenakte haben das ist eine Sache
80%, das bedeutet das sind ungefähr 60
Millionen Menschen das sind dann 20.000
also Apotheken das sind 150.000 parken
das sind etwa
1.000.800 oder 1700 Krankenhäusern alle
werden vernetzt sind daran ist
10-15 Jahre gearbeitet worden ich mache
das Geschäft jetzt als Minister ein Jahr
erinnern sich an meine Worte das heute
nächstes Jahr aus das Gesetz haben wir
jetzt im Sommer im Kabinett zwei große
digitalgesetze wir werden auch die Daten
nutzbar machen das heißt was Sie
beschreiben diese riesigen
Effizienzreserven die sind da aber ich
arbeite wirklich seit Stunde nur
parallel zu kurvig an der Vorbereitung
dieser großen strukturgesetze
Arzneimittel Digitalisierung Krankenhaus
und medizinische Versorgungszentren da
machen wir auch ein Gesetz dass diese
Investoren betriebenen
Versorgungszentren aufhören die 15%
Gewinn aus dem System herausziehen daher
machen wir viele Gesetze die lange lange
Zeit liegen geblieben sind